modesty we're not working on this
industry hi my name is Yoli and I'm a
chef de cuisine hi my name is Dana and I
am a sous chef and today we will be
playing never have I ever
I'm nervous what I ready yes ah okay
never have I ever eaten a customer's
leftovers no if it's like a really
expensive cut of meat and they didn't
finish it for some weird reason wild
reason then yeah yeah I'm gonna get it
yeah I'll be like a sandwich like I'm
not gonna eat someone's like half yeah
we got standards never have I ever
forgotten to wash my hands before
cooking ready one two three we wash our
hands a lot and their sinks everywhere
so there's no excuse games - there's
more sinks than staff
oh yeah all right next question never
have I ever messed up someone's order on
purpose think about that one I have an
explanation I have not I just feel that
sometimes people order like oh I want to
stick medium rare plus and you just have
to say you know what I personally think
you don't even know what you're talking
about just for future reference medium
rare plus medium plus p.m. well Plus
does not exist and I will cook it to my
liking yeah never have I ever blamed the
mistake I made on someone else yes I
will blame you if the recipe is a little
off like it's a little smudged
yeah depending on the cook sometimes I'm
like what are you talking about I never
said you could do that nothing major
though I take ownership for most of my
mistakes
never have I ever injured myself in the
kitchen while cooking yesterday I
thought I was being about us trying to
fry without tongs so I was trying to
like do it and it splattered all over me
and so now I know these like things that
look like warts on my hand it happens
all the time
you're cooking you're chopping too fast
you're trying to get something done you
cut yourself and it just sucks I started
working at this place and they told me
right before I got there that somebody
was grinding me and they didn't use that
stick that it comes with and he stuck
his hand and paramedics had to take the
entire like meat grinder and then they
had to like take it apart in the
hospital
that sucks those meat grinders are
expensive that exciting and unafraid
never have I ever reheated food in the
microwave for a customer I have not I
have it was during a banquet and if all
the steaks were cooked perfectly to
medium-rare and somebody wanted theirs
cooked well done immediately and a well
done steak takes about 20 minutes and
they he wanted it now so let's wrap it
up put it in the microwave for like five
minutes
take it out it's well done and you know
what he ate it up loved it we didn't
tell him don't tell anybody never have I
ever had to use expired ingredients in a
dish I was making um yeah no no the last
thing you want is like food poisoning
we're in charge of ordering the stuff if
you order too much you just have to
control it on your produce and how you
order yeah but when I'm cooking at home
I'm like an expired like when you're
cooking at home they're just like you
got a train your stomach to to power
that are like things like that yeah but
not at work not at work no dead in the
camera
all right never have I ever pretended to
cook something to impress someone
Oh pretended to cook something to
impress someone
no look the closest I've come to that is
using msg in my tasting that I just had
it in my pocket it's just in case it was
like a security thing
she loves them I love msg I was like you
know what don't don't be that freaked
out it's not that bad she came in and do
a tasting and everything went well and
then she's like oh you know I put msg on
everything I didn't put on everything I
just had it for backup never have I ever
found a mouse in the kitchen dead or
alive I both dead and I found one in a
michelin-star restaurant so how about
that huh no mine was just in the trap
they were doing construction and so if
you let the door open you're gonna run
inside for safety no mine was during
service never have I ever dropped food
on the ground and still used it uh hmm
that's a tough one no I have yeah I was
cooking for my friend I knew I was doing
well I have but I ate it I didn't serve
it I have no standards I dropped a steak
and I was like but I just put that on
the side made another one and I ate it
while I was cooking those delicious
well floorspace honesty all right last
one all right never have ever called
someone an idiot oh well I guess today
Oh perfect
I'm gonna do Oh Oh No Oh what are you
are you
say to the camera I actually worked for
him oh no just a donkey
[Music]